那啥事了，
呃，
龙飞姐，
我是先给你说一下我我的事情比较小，
我跟你做个复盘，
我两年前跟你连过麦，
然后当时你给了一些比较好的建议，
然后从工作生活，
包括我的心态方面，
我受到了非常大的鼓舞，
然后具体的这个我两年前跟你连线的时候，
一个月工资是7000块钱，
然后到现在的话，
今年是一年赚了30万，
我跟你连麦的意思是第一个就是你给了很多像我这种女性很大的力量，
然后呢，
你也在一直致力于带领着部分的女性从男人当中往前去走，
就是因为你也有宝宝了嘛，
我希望你就是身体健康，
然后平安喜乐，
你也给了我很振奋人心的毕见我，
我就很感谢你，
就是，
所以我一定得跟你连这个麦，
这是第一，
而且就是之前跟你连麦的时候，
刚好也是12月份，
就是也算是整两年，
我觉得我算是拿到一个比较好的答卷吧，
因为我自己就是学历不是特别高，
然后也受到了很多的挫折，
再加上我是独生子女，
然后完了又是农村家庭，
就是这么多年打拼过来，
我就非常感谢抖音，
然后遇到了龙飞姐啊，
就是之前看你案例也好，
今年连麦也罢，
或者说是跟你有连系，
有一些连接，
我觉得就是我非常荣幸，
然后在你这边受到了很大的鼓舞和能量，
然后我希望你开心一点。
还有就是网络上的声音太多了，
就是因为我自己也是做电商相关的，
我希望就是太多的负能量，
就是不要把你淹没，
如果说你觉得精力足的话就做做直播，
精力不足的话，
我希望你好好生活，
嗯，
然后啊，
千万不要哭，
不要哭，
然后我就是现在的话，
工作就稍微遇到了一点瓶颈，
就是我这个人经常容易老破防，
就是我我需要一直拿到正反馈，
然后我我特别希望拿到我的领导，
我的同事给我的这些比较正面的反馈，
然后我自己也通过您的这个推荐，
然后看了一些心理学方面的书，
我觉得讨好型人格比较严重，
嗯，
我想问一下，
就是比如说您在求学，
或者说您在工作的过程当中呢，
是否呃有一些阶段，
然后有遇到一些挫折，
一些困难，
然后你有没有什么自己的方法，
然后进行了一些调节，
我希望你给我分享一下，
嗯，
我我原谅啊，
就是我刚参加工作的时候，
那会儿也是讨好型人格，
讨好型人格最大的原因是因为自己，
呃，
背后空无一人，
没有任何的背景，
没有任何的资源，
没有任何的依靠，
也没有一个亲人在自己的身边可以保护自己，
所以那个时候刚上班的时候，
几乎是在呃全单位对所有的人都是笑脸相迎，
对，
嗯，
可能会。
能力比较强的人，
可能我还会拍马屁，
嗯，
反正就是说基本上在单位上工作了这些年，
就是属于那种谁都不敢得罪谁，
谁的坏话都不敢说，
哪怕说自己瞧不上的一些前辈，
瞧不上的一些下三滥的那些手段，
我也不敢说那是那个阶段，
那个阶段的我什么时候我发现自己才开始改变了啊，
就是自己做独立律师了之后，
因为自己做独立律师之后呢，
就相当于自己没有老板了，
就是自己能够，
呃，
完全靠，
就是完全靠着自己的专业能吃上这碗饭了，
那个时候才开始稍微硬气一点，
稍微硬气一点的话，
就是我不喜欢的人，
你要叫我去吃饭，
我就不去了，
我不欣赏男人，
你他叫我去聚会，
我就找理由，
我就不去了。
再到后来我想想，
可能是我35岁之后，
我的挣钱能力开始放大了，
35岁之后，
我大概一年就是账面上啊，
就是营业额能做到小，
嗯，
八十万一百万那个，
那个时候我就知道我没有必要再看他们的脸色，
对于那些我不喜欢的人，
我拉黑就拉黑我我不希防的人，
对吧，
我不想交往就不想交往，
我不回短信我就不回短信，
大概是这样一个过程，
那你要问我是什么力量能够支撑自己改变的话，
那就是自己的收入越来越高。
自己挣钱的那个能力夯实了，
我确信我就算得罪了你，
也不影响以后我自己的挣钱，
也不影响我自己以后的生存，
那我心里的那个底气就上来了，
嗯，
从35岁，
从35岁那会儿开始，
就是我喜欢谁就跟谁交往，
我欣赏谁，
我就努力的表达，
我就非常大方的表达，
我欣赏你哪个点，
大家我人际关系还就是就是那句话，
当我自己做一个真诚的人的时候，
我的人际关系就是非常的简单干净且正向反馈，
有能力。
自己还很弱小的时候，
你有很多那些人际关系，
你不得不去维护的时候，
你就会内耗，
特别内耗自己，
所以你要说，
哎，
有什么可以借鉴的东西的话，
那就是一门心思，
呃，
搞钱，
一门心思自己赚钱，
就想想我不知道对我什么时候能挣到足够多的钱，
就像美国有一个那个演员叫刘玉玲，
他讲的那个就是存一笔钱，
存一笔什么钱呢？
就是Fuck you money,
对吧，
就是存到这笔钱了之后，
我可以对所有我不喜欢的人说，
滚你的。
就是性的，
嗯明的，
然后罗菲姐我还是要表达一些我的声音，
就是我我我觉得就是你中间不是有断播嘛，
然后你昨天我俩直播之后，
就是大家很多评价也好呀，
或者一些声音也好，
我我觉得就是坏事谈间里，
好事不出门，
你比方说你像你帮助我了，
然后完了我给你反馈，
我是不是我得挑时间，
所以就是可能很多姐妹她受到你的帮助，
但是有一些姐妹不会表达，
或者没有给你留言，
我希望就是大家在冥冥中当中，
你要感受到更多的爱意，
然后希望嗯，
就是你一定是你不要被情绪裹挟，
就是很多人就是真的是有毛病，
所以不要搭理他们，
然后直播间其他姐妹我也觉得就是萌菲姐，
她有时候给的一些观点，
她是针对个人的，
就举个例子，
刚才呃姐给我的观点就是，
就是比较偏向于我这个情况，
我这个状态的，
然后呢，
家在提取观点的时候，
就是也是查漏补缺，
再一个就是你挑你能接收的吸收，
然后不要被网络上那种拼接剪辑，
恶意剪辑，
然后被带着乱跑，
还有就是行，始终相信我，
一直我就我就只相信你，
其实道理我都懂，
但是我就希望你相信我，
所以我说我给你今天连个麦啊，
然后还有就是呃，
其他的姐妹就是，
呃，
我觉得大家靠自己双手赚钱的时候，
你就是。
不守心向上，
然后不跟任何人裹挟的日子真的是非常爽，
就是因为我刚开始就是我也工作十来年了，
我今年29就上完初中出来上班，
工作十来年了，
说说减没下存款完了家里头爸妈需要钱的时候，
我也就能帮衬帮衬，
然后我现在就是找到了自己比较喜欢的工作，
然后也就是很努力，
然后就是他会有一种让你很安定的感觉，
然后很多姐妹可能比如说婚姻啊，
工作呀，
情绪啊这些问题，
大家可以到都就是汲取一些经验，
那网络上除了龙飞姐姐还有其他比较好的博主，
大家就是就是讲好的需求，
但是我觉得有时候如果说大家有失偏颇的时候，
就是我希望多多理解吧，
因为有时候像龙飞姐她有一些观点啊，
就是我有，
我经常跟你直播嘛，
我都深信很自责了，
有时候你可能讲的案例别人会随意拼接，
然后其他姐妹可能会被误导，
希望大家不要被误导，
然后就是好好赚钱，
然后我觉得还是要相信美好吧，
就是刚开始咱们开会有点小低落哈，
大家还是要相信美好，
因为就是可能有一些事情很无力，
但是大家如果说学会学会好规则，
运用好规则，
然后努力让我们女性也能成为规则的制定者，
然后大家都向上走去走，
然后希望大家越来越。
勇敢吧，
就就就我希望给所有的姐妹有一些这些正向的一些反馈吧，
谢谢你啊，
我特别高兴我接到你的反馈，
不管你是收入提高了，
还是认知提高了，
还是自己的生命力顽强了，
我发自内心的为你高兴，
希望你能越来越好，
希望你这辈子都能主宰自己的命运的方向，
成为自己的主人。
姐，
咱不是还有个什么三亚之约呢，
你别忘了啊，
等着等着，
等着，
到时候跟你相约吧，
好好，
希望你开心，
那我没有其他问题了，
祝福所有的姐妹新的一年无忧无惧，
平安喜乐，
拜拜，
嗯，
谢谢你，
拜拜。